how you doing so nice I'm starting to
really hate people hate people you in
the right person to this I I go to shake
a guy's hand the other day he goes on
and a no I just washed that's when I
wanna shake your hand
not when it's filthy oh good timing I
was about to wash now I can fit do you
see what I'm talking about
are you with me or you can't we've lost
our minds jerk I'm not afraid of germs
I'm not one of these Millennials you
Millennials you dumb Millennials came
onto our planet and you changed too much
stuff and it's upsetting us it's upset
oh oh he called us dumb he called us
dumb oh the little millennial word
police are gonna attack me after the
show
Oh Warren he called us dumb when he
called us dumb how about these people on
Twitter that have five followers why
don't you just text everybody you know
they're out there right now judging me
on a criteria I did not grow up on I
don't I don't know how to act anymore I
mean can you t be a man in bed anymore I
mean what what's the fun talk like for
you people oh ho oh are you my little
eco are you my little strong independent
equal
yes you are you're my little eco you're
my little eco
you have to have sex on your side so
nobody's in a power position this stupid
there's no common sense
there's no couple that doesn't need to
work does it there's no common sense
anymore I eat that don't we're getting
dumber
like I'm watching a reality show this is
what the guys that you ready for this
guy said I'm gonna turn my life around
360 degrees good you'll be right back
where you started you go 180 a stop you
you can go 360 lights gone full suck
let's go 720 go go go just keep going
don't 1082 just keep going in circles
until you pass out from your gut
the war it's malarkey
it's mullah the work I go into Turkey
read even less there's no comments I go
and I go into target you ever going to
target I go into target i buy a bunch of
stuff I use a coupon I pay with my
American Express the guy goes sir sir I
need to see an ID
what for he goes you know to make sure
the card isn't stolen I said I just used
a coupon why would I use a coupon if the
card was stolen
oh you've got me there I'm busted 15
minutes ago I hit the guy over the head
with a bat I felt bad I wanted to save
them 75 cents on tide I lost my mark
where am I supposed to be it's like it's
like every year my cable bill goes up by
like a hundred dollars and I have to
call and threaten to leave
I'm not even nice anymore I just call
him up I go lower the bill they go who
is this I go to me now lower the bill
you know what just show Sokolow the pill
they go what's your address I said I'm
calling to lower Mike I'm sorry
are people stealing people's identities
and lowering their cable bills
[Music]
is there some sort of epidemic I don't
know about what with my belt whoa a my
belt I don't care if somebody calls my
accident lower the belt then I have to
know anything about me my shoe size my
mother's maiden name my first pet where
I went to high school
lower the belt my next call you guys
should be why why did my bill go down
well some dumb millennial called and
there's no common sense I got a ticket I
got a ticket because the thieves in Los
Angeles are stealing off of our license
plates the little that the Dozen that
the registration year stick on and you
don't know your stickers missing because
you don't go out to your car every
morning to go there's my sticker still
there you don't know until you get a
ticket so I called the DMV I go hey
there's a mix-up I got a ticket but my
car's registered she goes sir sir you
need to prove to us that your car's
registered I said I'm sorry am I talking
to that DMV isn't that a little piece of
information you should have she goes sir
it's policy you need to send us a copy
of your registration I said I don't even
know where that is
she said we'd be happy to send you a
copy
[Applause]
I didn't even open up the envelope I
just wrote return to sender
thank you so much everybody
[Applause]
you